autre tentative de médiation la turquie
le président rajapaske par doan s'est
entretenu au téléphone avec son
homologue russe vladimir poutine il
réclame un cessez-le-feu général urgent
en ukraine un forum diplomatique se
tient la semaine prochaine à antalya le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov doit d'y participer la
correspondance à istanbul de ludovic de
foucauld
à quelques pas du consulat russe
d'istanbul des dizaines de personnes se
sont rassemblées ce dimanche en soutien
à l'ukraine en opposition à l'invasion
russe en ukraine parmi les slogans qu'on
peut entendre ici poutine fasciste
poutine terroristes mais aussi des
slogans comme turquie ne soit pas
silencieuse et tient tôt aux côtés de
ton frère ukrainien turquie ferme ton
espace aérien à rassemblement qui a eu
lieu ce dimanche alors qu'un peu plus
tôt dans la journée le président turc
s'est entretenu par téléphone avec son
homologue russe est chez hyper douanes
qui a demandé à vladimir poutine un
cessez le feu immédiat seule condition
pour le président turc pour s'assurer
une condition humanitaire plus favorable
et pour ouvrir la voie à une solution
politique négociée
un appel qui fait écho aux initiatives
déployées par l'administration turque
qui espèrent rassembler dans les
prochains jours au forum diplomatique
d'antalya du 11 au 13 mars au 13 mars
prochain les chefs de la diplomatie
russe et ukrainienne